[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in the last couple of months i've made a
few videos on various dark witches and
wizards
and discussed whether or not they're
able to produce patronuses
in the comments section of these videos
there was quite a bit of discussion
surrounding the relationship between
dementors and death eaters
some people even asked can dementors
kiss or
hurt death eaters are they able to suck
out the soul of dark witches and wizards
those who aren't pure of heart let me
start off by saying
that just because most dark witches and
wizards can't produce a patronus
it's not entirely accurate to say that
they would never need them
it's only very unlikely that they would
we all know that a patronus charm is the
only effective defense against
dementor and the reality is that most
dark witches and wizards
lack the capability to produce one so
why aren't they more threatened by the
presence of dementors
why is it for the most part okay that
they don't have any form of defense
against them the reason for this is
because in a weird sort of way
dementors and death eaters are on the
same side both
sharing the common goal of reading the
world of light happiness
altruism and basically just anything
positive in nature
both death eaters and dementors are
known to revel in the darkness
each party finding solace and
satisfaction only in the prospect of the
downfall
of what light is left in the world their
reliance is almost preordained
because of these shared values however
just because they share these values and
goals it doesn't necessarily mean that
death eaters or dark wizards in general
for that matter
are entirely safe against them in fact
if a dementor made the decision to
attack a death eater
they would likely be more defenseless
than their virtuous wizard counterpart
the death eater would kiss them their
soul would be ripped from their body
and they would have no defense to speak
of and that's because dementors are
repelled
by positive energy forces i do theorize
however that dementor's advances on a
death eater
would be a lot more drawn out than what
we are used to seeing
in the books and films we've seen and
heard of dementors kissing people
and it doesn't seem to take long for
their soul to be taken from them
their positive life force is a veritable
treat for the dementors dark
and starkly contrasting presence so
provided that a death eater is a much
darker life force in general
i would expect that it is more of an
undertaking for dementor
to suck out their soul the very presence
of a dementor is enough to incite
feelings
of hopelessness depression and darkness
but i would expect that many of these
negative feelings
aren't even on the death eaters radar so
many of them
have sociopathic tendencies they're not
like normal people
so my theory is that dementors would
have to work a bit harder
to strip them of their soul though the
relationship between death eaters and
dementors
is scarcely discussed we do know that
they are used as guards of azkaban
prison
where the darkest and most foul witches
and wizards are held
i really can't see a reason for why they
would be used there if their
effectiveness
as guards wasn't completely valid you
might ask
why they just contend with guarding a
prison the book answers this
when it is implied that the mere
presence of the prisoners in a hopeless
state
is enough to ensure that the dementors
are fed
in the prisoner of azkaban hagrid
explains this
think that matters to them they don't
care long as they've got a couple
hundred humans stuck in there with them
so they can leech all the happiness out
of them they don't give a damn who's
guilty and who's not
so i hope that answers the question no
one is safe from the dementors
not even dark wizards what do you guys
think do you think that it takes a
dementor longer
to suck out the life force of a dark
wizard or is it the same amount of time
because their souls are already so
damaged
do they even want to eat the souls of
evil wizards let me know down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
harry
[Music]
you